the film Captain America the Winter
Soldier is coming to theaters in comic
books the Winter Soldier is Captain
America's former sidekick brainwashed
and turned against his own country by a
Soviet spy network
fortunately forcibly causing someone to
betray everyone and everything they ever
loved and believed in is just something
in the movies or is it I'm rusty warden
this is a special wired edition of
science fiction the series where I break
down the real science behind comic book
in sci-fi superheroes and tell you how
to become superhuman to brainwash
someone is to cause them to drastically
change their attitudes and beliefs the
term brainwashing was first used by
journalist Edward hunter in 1950 after
American POWs falsely confessed to
committing biological warfare in Korea
on behalf of the US government
psychologist robert jay lifton wanted to
find out exactly what the Chinese did so
he interviewed these former POWs and
wrote a book explaining the step-by-step
process of thought reform the first step
is an assault on identity you do not
like ice cream do you know how many cows
were hurt trying to give you your ice
cream agree with me that you don't like
ice cream hello are you are you really
sad are you pretending to be sad all
right good work everybody give yourself
a round of applause are they giving you
enough pillows
are you ready to talk about how horrible
you are for all the stuff with the ice
cream I know you're feeling really down
on yourself but you know what it's not
your fault
you know whose fault it is Ben and Jerry
here I'm gonna turn on the camera this
is gonna make you feel a lot better I
want you to read this statement
denouncing Ben and Jerry and then I'm
gonna give you a sniper rifle I want you
to shoot Jerry don't worry about Ben
we've got a guy one cell over he's gonna
take care of it it's that easy
but the oppressor does need to have
absolute control over the subject they
need to be able to disrupt sleep
restrict diet and physically punish the
individual this all makes scientific
study of brainwashing ethically
impossible you can't replicate these
conditions without causing grave injury
to your subjects of course that didn't
stop the CIA from conducting their own
brainwashing experiments in 1953 the
program was called MKULTRA and used
hypnosis electroshock treatment
radiological implants and LSD on
unwitting civilians after the program
was exposed and shut down it was
determined that the CIA had learned
absolutely nothing because the CIA
operatives weren't trained as scientists
the only thing they accomplished was to
put a lot of innocent people through a
harrowing ordeal Captain America would
not have approved so even though there
are no rigorous scientific studies
providing hard evidence of brainwashing
many psychologists still believe it's
possible why is that that's because
we've seen examples of dramatic attitude
shifts outside experimental settings in
1973 two armed men attempted to rob a
bank in Stockholm Sweden the police
showed up and a hostage situation ensued
that lasted six days when the police
attempted a rescue they were attacked by
the hostages and the hostages tried to
protect their captors after being freed
one of the hostages set up a fund to pay
for the robbers legal fees from this
event came the term
Stockholm Syndrome a year later Patty
Hearst was abducted within a very short
period of time she went from an
unwilling hostage to an eager
participant in a domestic terrorist
group
another reason psychologists believe in
brainwashing is because our brains
aren't nearly as static as we once
thought they were up until 20 years ago
we thought the structure of our brain
was fixed at adulthood
now we know that multiple factors such
as pain drugs exercise inactivity
temperature the food we can change the
shape size and structure of our brain
whenever our brains are introduced to a
new stimulus a neural pathway is formed
the information about that stimulus its
sound meaning and associations are
perceived by our senses and travel
through those neural pathways to our
brain repetition of that stimulus causes
a physiological change in that normal
pathway it makes it stronger the
stronger the neural pathway the more
easily we accept those messages that's
why repetition is such a vital aspect of
brainwashing and modern technology is
driven home just how easily our minds
can be manipulated if you apply
electromagnetic fields to specific areas
of the brain you can pacify someone
caused them to hallucinate even turn off
their sense of morality and recently two
scientists from the University of
Washington have developed a way to
remotely control another person's mind
right now you can only induce slight
movements and you can't do it to someone
who's not willing a slight movement is a
far cry from forcibly changing someone's
core values but it's not hard to imagine
a near future where someone combines
modern technology with classic coercion
methods and creates a frightening ly
effective form of brainwashing but until
the day a totalitarian government or a
monolithic corporate entity robs us of
our free will and sense of self enjoy
your autonomy and your independent cause
and maybe keep an eye on your best
friend because for all you know he may
be a Winter Soldier
thanks for watching subscribe to Wired
if you want to check out more episodes
of science friction check out the link
below
[Music]